Because the effect of warfarin is to ultimately
decrease the amount of available vitamin K, which
can in turn regulate blood clotting. The amount
of vitamin K available from the environment can also
influence the efficacy of warfarin. So we just
talked about how changing the VKORC1 levels can affect
the efficacy of warfarin. But VKORC1 is acting
to regulate the amount of reduced vitamin K around.
So we can supplant the actions of
VKORC1to a certain extent by supplying vitamin k
in our diet. Leafy green vegetables have high
vitamin K, and so do other foods. You
can also take vitamin supplements, or find vitamin K in other sources. So if you
changed your diet to be high in vitamin K, would the same dose as warfarin be
more effective or less effective?